c'est vrai que la loi va être durci pour
les squatteurs Matthieu tu dis non tu
n'es pas d'accord mais déjà c'est
horrible on est en train d'assimiler en
fait SDF à des personnes on va créer des
SDF si on empêche des personnes de voler
le bien de personnes qui ont travaillé
pour avoir ce bien pardon moi je suis
pas en train de dire qu'ils vont le
mettre le mauvais rôle qu'il faut mettre
des gens dans la rue il faut créer des
logements sociaux il faut s'organiser
pour que les gens savent pas dans la rue
mais c'est pas aux personnes qui ont
payé toutes leurs vies pour avoir
pendant 20 ans une hypothèque pour
s'acheter un appartement de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait plus de SDF dans la
rue je ne comprends même pas comment on
peut on peut discuter de ce sujet en
fait il faut absolument on l'a vu on est
plein de cas ici il faut il faut que la
loi soit beaucoup plus sévère là-dessus
pour que le squat n'existe plus vous
allez mettre des familles à la rue si ça
vous voulez les familles avec des
enfants à la rue et les familles étaient
dehors des voleurs il faut c'est famille
là bien sûr qu'elle doivent reprendre
leur logement mais elles sont beaucoup
moins nombreuses que je te dis toi tu
veux tout le monde non mais non
exactement